foreign
[Music]
traffic private has its benefits but
there are some cases when you might want
Google Cloud VMware engine or gcve
instances to have access to the public
internet while still being secure let's
dive into why and how to set that up
let's get started by understanding the
purpose of the public IP address service
and its benefits the public IP service
is required to connect from the internet
to a workload VM management Appliance or
load balancer running inside your gcve
private Cloud the benefits include
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack prevention is automatically
enabled for the public IP address
traffic monitoring and real-time
mitigation of common Network level
attacks and protection and Mitigation Of
attacks across the entire scale of the
global Network
be aware of the following caveats while
using the public IP service
before enabling the public IP service
and allocating a public IP address to a
workload VM the internet access network
service must be enabled in a specific
region
you are allowed to reserve a maximum of
100 public IP addresses for the primary
VPC Network connected to VMware engine
while assigning a public IP address to
vcenter NSX or hcx manager it is
strongly recommended to open only Port
443 to a specific set of IP addresses
finally remember the public IP service
is disabled on gcve by default
to enable internet access and public IP
service in your gcbe private Cloud you
must have the identity and access
management or I am role VMware engine
service admin this role has admin access
to VMware engine resources and the
required permissions to perform these
tasks
let's see in action how to perform these
tasks one by one first let's configure
the internet access and public IP
service
go to the VMware engine page in the
Google Cloud console then Network
regional settings click edit on the
region of your interest if the region
doesn't yet exist add the region by
clicking on ADD region toggle internet
access and public IP service to enabled
in the edge Services cider enter the
address range to use when addressing the
VMware engine public IP Gateway then
click submit note it may take a few
minutes for both the services to be
enabled let's allocate a public IP
address for a workload VM
in the VMware engine page go to network
public IPS click allocate
give a name for the public IP address
entry I'll set mine as my public IP
select a private Cloud that contains the
workload via select a location where you
want to serve the allocated public IP
in the attached local address field
enter the local IP address of the VM
that you want to assign this public IP
address to click submit allocation of
the IP address can take a few minutes
once it's complete the new entry will
show up on the public IPS page with the
status of operational yay the VM is now
allocated with a public IP address
to access the VM you first need to
create a firewall table with appropriate
firewall rules because Ingress via
public IP is disabled by default
to create a firewall table navigate to
the network firewall table section click
create new firewall table
enter the name for the table let's say
my firewall table click submit to save
the firewall table
next let's specify the subnets that we
want the firewall table rules to apply
to in the table
in the network firewall tables page
select the firewall table we just
created by example my firewall table in
the attached subnet tab click attach to
a subnet
select the private Cloud you want to
attach the firewall table to select the
nsxt edge Uplink 1 subnet of that
private Cloud click submit repeat the
above steps for nsxt Edge Uplink 2
subnet that is part of that private
cloud
to restrict access to your private Cloud
you can create your own firewall Rules
by following these steps go to network
firewall tables and select the firewall
table we just created
the default rules will populate then
you'll be able to click create new
firewall rule
we'll just call this my firewall rule
we'll set it with a priority of 100 set
the source as my current public IP
address
we'll then set the destination to the
public IP address that I just set for my
destination VM and the port range of
3389 because we want to RDP to this
machine
then click done
but once that finishes you'll have a new
firewall rule in place
the following table describes the
properties in a firewall rule
you can verify the firewall rule is
working as expected through SSH or RDP
session to the VM
to learn more about public IPS internet
access service and firewall tables for
gcve check out the following
documentation thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]